اكد البيان الختامي الاجتماعي العقبه بين
مسؤولين فلسطينيين واسرائيليين وبمشاركه
اردنيه مصريه امريكيه اكد التزام الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي بالاتفاقيات
السابقه بينهما كما كان البيان ان اللقاء
الذي وجه برفض فلسطيني واسرائيلي وجاء في
سياق تصعيد اسرائيلي بالضفه والقدس اكد
اتفاق الجانبين على التهدئه بينهما
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ابرز نتائج التي
خلص اليها اجتماع العقبه وما مدى مواءمه
السياقات التي ياتي فيها للتوصل الى
تفاهمات بين الجانبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي
وما هي اسباب مسارعه فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه وغزه لرفض مشاركه
السلطه في هذا الاجتماع وما دلاله دعوه
مسؤولين اسرائيليين للانسحاب منها وما مدى
قدره واشنطن على استكمال الخطوات التي
اقرها اجتماع العقبه وما الضمانات التي
يمكن ان تمنحها للفلسطينيين للتاكد من
التزام اسرائيل باي تهدئه
[موسيقى]
بحسب البيان الختامي الاجتماعي العقبه
الذي عاقد بدعوه اردنيه وبمشاركه مصريه
وامريكيه بين مسؤولين اميين وسياسيين
وصفوا بانهم كبار من الجانبين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني فان الجانبين الفلسطينيه
والاسرائيليه اكد التزامهما بجميع
الاتفاقات السابقه بينهما وبالعمل على
تحقيق السلام العادل والدائم كما اكد
الجانبان الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي وفق
البيان
التزامهما بخفض التصعيد ومنع المزيد من
العنف واضاف البيان ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والسلطه الفلسطينيه
اعلنت استعدادهما المشترك
والتزامهما بالعمل الفوري لوقف الاجراءات
الاحاديه الجانب لمده ثلاثه الى سته اشهر
كما اكد البيان الختامي الاجتماعي العقبه
ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه اعربت عن
استعدادها لوقف مناقشه اقامه اي وحدات
استيطانيه جديده لمده اربعه اشهر ووقف
اقرار اي بؤر استيطانيه جديده لمده سته
اشهر كما تم تاكيد ايضا على اهميه الحفاظ
على الوضع التاريخي القائم في الاماكن
المقدسه بالقدس وعلى الوصايه الهاشميه
والدوري الاردني الخاص في المدينه وفق نص
البيان لكن وكاله رويترز نقلت عن مسؤول
اسرائيليا قوله انهم اكدوا بالعقبه انه لا
تغيير على الموافقه السابقه لبناء تسع
مستوطنات بالضفه الغربيه وان الاطراف في
اجتماع العقبه ستشكل لجنه لفحص استئناف
التنسيق الامنيه الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
يؤسفني ان اقول انه ما تعرض له
الفلسطينيون في هذا الاجتماع هو خداع كبير
ويؤسفني ايضا ان اقول ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه عادت لنفس النهج الذي فشل على
مدار 32 عاما
وعمليا العوده للتمسك بالاتفاقيات هي
مخالفه لقرارات منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
والمجلس المركزي الذي دعا الى التحلل من
هذه الاتفاقات ولكن الامر الاهم فيما
يتعلق بالاستيطان هذا خدعه كبيره لانه
البيان يقول ان اسرائيل تلتزم بعدم مناقشه
وحدات جديده
لسته الاربعه اشهر وعدم المناقشه بؤر
جديده لسته اشهر ولكنها لا تحتاج لذلك
لانه اسرائيل اقرت عشر الاف وحده
استيطانيه
واقرت 13 بؤره استطانيه جديده وسيستمروا
بالعمل بها واصلا مجلس التخطيط الذي يقر
هذه المستوطنات لن ينعقد اصلا قبل هذه
القمه الا بعد ثلاثه شهور اذا هاي عمليه
خداع كبيره وهذا يطرح السؤال هل ان
الاستيطان قبل هذا اللقاء مقبول وبعده غير
مقبول او انه بعد ست اشهر سيصبح انا برايي
هذا التخلي عن مبدا اساسي وكبير وهو ان
الاستيطان برمته غير شرعي وغير قانوني
ودعيني اشير ايضا الى ما اعلنه قبل قليل
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي اسمه المتطرف
والذي هو وزير في وزاره الدفاع قال هذه
مسؤوليه الضفه الغربيه ولا نوقف التخطيط
ليوم واحد اذا هذه عمليه خداع كبيره فيما
يتعلق بموضوع الاستيطان وفيما يتعلق
بموضوع عمليا واضح ان هذا الاجتماع قرر
عوده التنسيق الامني ايضا المرفوض شعبيا
ونعمه نخشاه انه محاوله للضغط على الجانب
الفلسطيني لجره الى صراع داخلي في وقت نحن
احوج ما نكون فيه للوحده
المخرجات كما كما يعني يرويها البيان لنقل
هي الهدف الهدف هو وقت الاجراءات احاديه
الجانب وقف التصعيد الامني محاوله فرض
تهدئه وهدنه خصوصا اننا مقبلون على شهر
رمضان المبارك اذا ما المشكله اذا تحقق
ذلك
ما هو لن يتحقق نحن جربنا من قبل قالوا
بعد سحب قرار القرار الخاطئ من السلطه
بسحب مشروع القرار امام مجلس الامن قالوا
انهم ايضا سيوقفوا اجتياحات المدن وصارت
مجزره نابلس والان الان في هذه اللحظات
تجري اعتداءات وحشيه للمستوطنين على
الفلسطينيين في كل انحاء الضفه الغربيه
بما في ذلك اطلاق رصاص على المواطنين
الامنين بما في ذلك حرق بيوت كما جرى حرق
بيت في حواره بما في ذلك طعن فلسطينيين كل
كلام فارغ المساله الاساسيه ان هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لن تردع بهذا الكلام
وهي لن ترضع الا بمقاومتها على الارض
وبفرض العقوبات والمقاطعه عليها وليس
العوده الى التنسيق الامني معها هذا هو
الخطوره في الامر ودعني اقول انه يعني هاي
القرارات الجائره التي صدرت شو يعني وقف
التخطيط للوحدات جديده ما هي الوحدات
قائمه ويعني السماح بالاستمرار في بناء 13
مستوطنه جديده وهذا امر لم يحدث منذ عقود
انا برايي المخرجات كلها تدل على ان
الجانب الفلسطيني كان ضعيفا في هذا اللقاء
وضعف السلطه لن يعالج بالعوده للتنسيق
الامني بل يعالج بالتوجه للوحده الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه وبتوحيد الصف الوطني الفلسطيني
الذي بدا مختلفا تماما بسبب ان غالبيه
القوى الفلسطينيه بما فيها قوه منظمه
التحرير الغالبيه قوى منظمه التحرير كانت
ضد عقد هذا اللقاء مثل ما كانت ضد سحب
القرار من مجلس الامن سيد جون نيفينجر في
واشنطن الى الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي لا
الشيء سيتحقق من هذه الوعود بدليل ان وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي خرج وقال الاستيطان
الاستيطاريه ستتس ستستمر والاستيطان
سيستمر اكثر من ذلك هو دعا الى ضرب المدن
الفلسطينيه بالدبابات طيب ماذا حققنا اذا
من هذه هذه القمه وهذا الاجتماع
الله
ان الصوره الاكبر هنا هي اننا نرى ان
اسرائيل تتصرف بالطرق جديده وسالب جديده
هي طرق او اساليب غير بنائه
وبالتالي اعتقد ان الاحتجاجات التي نسمعها
من الفلسطينيين في الوقت الحالي هي فعلا
واضحه جدا
وانك وان كل ما كل الاشارات الى التفاهمات
ماضيه لم يبدو انها لم تعد النافذه او
مطبقه وبالتالي ان موقف امريكا وخاصه
اداره فايد والتي لا امثلها لكن بالتاكيد
اعمل مع حزب الديمقراطي
اعتقد هذا وقت منحاوله ان نجد ما هي
الخيارات متوفره لان لا يبدو ان هناك لا
يثبت ان هناك
كان امريكا لديها فعلا شريك في اسرائيل
يحاول ان يحقق اي نتيجه مقبوله من وجهه
نظر امريكيه
وهذا طبعا امر صعب للغايه انما تقوم
باداره بايدن هي انهم
يتواصلون ويستمعون يحاول الحديث مع
الاخرين
لايجاد اي طريقه كالتي تريدها امريكا او
اذا تلعب دورا هاما ومفيدا
لجعل
للتوجيه لجعل الموقف مفيد جيدا ولكن مجرد
الجلوس في وقت الناس يتعرضون للاذى
ويفتقدون الامن الضروري وبالتالي
الناس من جهات لا بد ان يناقشوا كم طريقه
معالجه ذلك هذا امر ايجابي بحذاته لكن
السؤال الاكبر او الموضوع الاكبر حاليا
وجهه نظرت جميع وبالتاكيد وجهه نظر امريكا
هي ان ان الهدف النهائي او
الشيء النهائي او الغرض النهائي ليس واضحا
ان الى اين تت الامور او لا يمكن لا يمكن
تتجه لاي مكان مقبول على الاقل مجرد نظر
امريكا طيب
هناك رفض من الطرفين من الجانب الاسرائيلي
ومن الجانب الفلسطيني الاجتماع العقبه
اجتماع العقبه الذي رفضه مسؤولون
اسرائيليون بينهم وزراء وصفت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه ايضا في غزه مشاركه السلطه فيه
بانها جريمه في حق الوطن لا يمكن السكوت
عنها وحذرت من تبعاته وحذر المجتمع واناث
من مخرجات اجتماع العقبه خاصه في ظل تصاعد
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه بحق الفلسطينيين
في الضفه الغربيه بما فيها القدس المحتله
كما شهدت مدن بضفه الغربيه مسيرات مندده
باجتماع العقبه ومشاره وبمشاركه السلطه
الفلسطينيه في هذا الاجتماع حيث طالب
فلسطينيون يتقدمهم مسلحون في مخيم جنين
المسؤولين في القياده الفلسطينيه
بالعدول عن هذه المشاركه كما خرجت مسيره
ضد الاجتماع في مخيم دهيشه للاجئين في
لحم طبعا ورد الان في خبر عاجل ان وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بنجفير انه
قال ما حدث في الاردن يبقى في الاردن هذا
يذكرنا دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي بالمقوله
الشهيره ما حدث فيغاس يبقى فيغاس يعني
كانه ما حدث هو عار يعني كيف تعلق على
كلام بن جفير
بين
يقود الحكومه الاسرائيليه هؤلاء المجرمين
المستوطنين المتطرفين كلاهما مستوطن
مستعمر وبالتالي طبعا هم الذين يقررون
المسار وانا براي كل قصه العقبه استخدمت
من قبل نتنياهو كمناوره للخداع بده يقول
للامريكان هيني عملت شيء ولكن في الواقع
هو لا يعمل شيء لانه مقاليد قبل الذهاب
الى اجتماع العقبه بيوم قرر نتنياهو ان
يمنح سموترش السيطره على الضفه الغربيه
والسيطره على كل المستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه ولذلك
لن نوقف حتى التخطيط لبناء مستوطنات لان
هذا اختصاصي اختصاصه فلذلك انا برايي
هؤلاء المتطرفون هم من يقررون المسار
السلطه الفلسطينيه ارتكبت خطئين الخطا
الاول سحب القرار من مجلس الامن والخطا
الثاني الذهاب الى هذا الاجتماع واخطر ما
في الامر تحويل الموضوع السياسي اساسا وهو
موضوع الاحتلال ونظام الابرتايد العنصري
وعدم شرعيه الاستيطان برمته
تحويله الى مجرد مساله امنيه كان الموضوع
مجرد تهدئه امنيه لا المساله الاكبر ان
هناك اكثر حكومه عنصريه واجراميه في تاريخ
المنطقه حكومه توصف بالفاشيه بسبب وجود
هؤلاء الفاشين وهؤلاء هم الذين يقررون
المسار لذلك انا برايي كان خطا كبيرا هذا
التوجه والان مطلوب انا برايي من السلطه
الفلسطينيه الاسراع في لملمه الصف الوطني
العوده لنهج الوحده الوطنيه العمل على
بناء قياده وطنيه فلسطينيه موحده تقود
النضال الوطني الفلسطيني وتقول الوطني في
وجه هذا الوطن الفلسطيني دعنا نستقبل ان
ينضم الينا في هذا النقاش الاستاذ منير
الجاوب وهو قيادي في حركه فتح ينضم الينا
من رام الله اهلا بك استاذ منير جاوب يعني
هناك رفض
لاجتماع النقب وحتى بن جفير سمعتي الى في
الخبر العاجل الى ما قاله عن هذه القمه
قال انه ما حدث في الاردن يبقى في الاردن
وكاننا
كل شيء ما الفائده اذا
يعني بدايه مساء الخير لك ولجميع
المشاهدين ولضيوفك الاعزاء اللي ما
الفائده الفائده
المرجوه من هذا اللقاء كانت هو الحديث
الاطول لمده ثلاث ساعات حول اسرانا
الابطال بضغط مصري واردني للتخفيف عليهم
وعلى ما يحدث معهم الان وهم متروكين وحيده
وحيدين بايدي السجان الاسرائيلي كان
الموقف الاردني والمصري مشرف جدا في الضغط
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه من غفير يستطيع
ان يتحدث ما يريد ويقول ما يريد ولكن هناك
تعهدات وضعتها اسرائيل على الطاوله ان
اقول لك سوف تقولون لي بان اسرائيل يعني
لا تؤمن بالتزاماتها ولا تنفذها هذا صحيح
ولكن ايضا نحن يجب ان نتحدث في كل قضايا
طيب اذا نظمناه ما الضمانات هذا هذا
السؤال يقودنا الى الحديث
الان الضمانات الموجوده
الوجود العربي مصر
والاردني الاشقاء الاردنيين وايضا
الوسيط الامريكي الذي تعهد بان هذه
التفاهمات سوف يكون لها طريق للتنفيذ باي
وسيله تحديدا فتح السفاره الفلسطينيه او
الممثليه الفلسطينيه في الولايات المتحده
وايضا فتح مكتب او سفاره او قنصليه
الولايات المتحده في القدس الشرقيه اريد
ان اضيف موضوع اخر تحدث به الاخ مصطفى
البرغوثي بخصوص القرار الذي سحب هو لم
يقدم قرار حتى يسحب بعدين هناك قرار رقم
اثنين ثلاثه اربعه كان هو الاهم الذي صوتت
عليه الولايات المتحده ضد الاستيطان
الاسرائيلي بالتالي السلطه الفلسطينيه لم
تقدم قرار حتى تسحب من قدم القرار او من
كان يحاول ان يقدم القرار نعم في موضوع
الاستيطان يعني هي هي الامارات العربيه
المتحده بالتالي القرار اثنين ثلاثه اربعه
هو قرار كان من اقوى القرارات التي اتخذت
في مجلس الامن بتصويت امريكي عليه ضد
الاستيطان ولكن ايضا بدون فائده في موضوع
التنسيق الامني
هلا موضوع التنسيق الامني وموضوع الامن لم
تذهب للقياده الفلسطينيه او الوفد
الفلسطينيه ليتحدث في بنود امنيه هم
تحدثوا ب 12 بند واضحات هذه البنود لها
علاقه باجراء الانتخابات الفلسطينيه
والسماح باجراءها في مدينه القدس تحدثوا
عن اسرار الابطال لاكثر من ثلاث الى اربع
ساعات ووصل الموضوع الى مشاجرات وصراخ في
هذه الجلسه وانا مسؤول عن حديثي قبل ان
ادخل الاستوديو تاكدت من هذه النقطه
تحدثوا عن موضوع التجميد الاستيطان
وبنغافير هو يستطيع ان يحل الحكومه الان
اذا لا يريد ان يوقف الاستيطان
لوحده هناك وزراء
هو يقول ما يريد ولكن انا اريد ان اقول لك
ماذا نقول نحن في حركه فتح لكل الجمهور
ولكل الفصائل ولابناء الفتح المعارضين
كلهم
اذا المصادر استاذ منير تقول قال مسؤول
سياسي مطلع انه تم تشكيل امنيه مشتركه
للعوده الى التنسيق الامني وهذا يعني
جهوزيه السلطه لمحاربه بين قوسين
الارهاب وفي المدن الفلسطينيه هل هذا
الكلام صحيح
طبعا هذا الكلام اخذ بالطريقه خطا ما تم
الاتفاق عليه هو فعلا تشكيل لجنه امنيه
مصريه اردنيه
اسرائيليه امريكيه وبوجود السلطه
الفلسطينيه لاعاده انتشار السلطه
الفلسطينيه في مناطق الف واعاده الاتفاق
كما كان قبل انتفاضه عام 2000 وللبدء في
مفاوضات مباشره بخصوص حلول نهائيه الموضوع
الفلسطيني ليس موضوع عمي مع اسرائيل نحن
لم نذهب لنتحدث في الامن نحن تحدثنا في 12
نقطه فلسطينيه واضحه لا ضرر فيها ولا
اعتقد بان هناك فلسطيني واحد يتحدثون في
الامن في ظل هذا التصعيد هذا الغليان
لاشتعال الاوضاع هذه المجازر هذا التصعيد
الذي تفعله كيف لا يكون يعني حاضرا على
الطاوله السلطه الفلسطينيه السلطه السلطه
الفلسطينيه لم توجد لحمايه اسرائيل السلطه
الفلسطينيه وجدت لتحقيق امال الشعب
الفلسطيني في الحريه والكرامه الاستقلال
وبنودها واضحه في اللقاء مع الاشقاء
الاردنيين والمصريين والاسرائيليين
والولايات المتحده تحدثوا في نقاط واضحه
الامن نقطه واحده هو كيف تعيد السلطه
الفلسطينيه السيطره وعدم دخول الاحتلال
الى المناطق الفلسطينيه وتوسيع حدود
صلاحيات السلطه الفلسطينيه والسيطره
الفلسطينيه على الارض هذا ما تم الحديث
فيه
نعم
لم تذهب السلطه الفلسطينيه للحديث مع
اسرائيل كيف سوف تلقي القبض على
الفلسطينيين هذا حديث غير صحيح ابدا ومن
يتحدث فيه ايضا يعني استطيع ان اقول بانه
كاذب طيب قبل ان اعود الى جون في واشنطن
موضوع الضمانات السيد مصطفى البرغوثي
مطمئن مقنع هذا الكلام الذي سمعناه من
منير الجاغوب
انا انصح الاخ منير ان يقرا البيان الذي
صدر لانه كل ما يقول ولا علاقه له بالبيان
الذي صدر اولا لا يوجد تجميد للاستيطان بل
سماح لاسرائيل بان تستمر في بناء 13
مستوطنه جديده
وسماح لاسرائيل بان تستمر في بناء العشر
الاف وحده استيطانيه جديده كل ما ورد في
البيان تاجيل التخطيط لمستوطنات جديده
لمده ثلاث الى سته اشهر وبعد ذلك تفضلوا
لذلك لا يوجد تجميد للاستيطان ثانيا
الامارات سحبت القرار لان هذا بالاتفاق مع
جانب الفلسطيني وليس منفرده لانه قدم
القرار
بالتساور مع الفلسطينيين وصحب بالتشاور مع
الفلسطينيين هذا واقع والجميع يعرفه الامر
الثالث الاهم انه للاسف العوده للتنسيق
الامني مخالفه لحتى للقرار السابق
ولقرارات منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
المشكله ان الجانب الاسرائيلي يريد ان
يحشر الفلسطينيين في موضوع التنسيق الامني
وهذا نخشاه نحن لا نريد ان يجر احد الاخوه
في فتح اعزاء علينا ومناضلين ونحن نريد ان
يكونوا معنا جميعا في الصف الوطني نحن لا
نقبل ان نجرب او يجر احد الى دائره الصراع
الداخلي اليوم نحن بحاجه لان نتصدى لهؤلاء
المستوطنين وانا اؤكد لك كل ما تنفي
العقبه سيتبخر لانه حتى هذه الالتزامات
التافهه بانه بدهم يعملوا تخطيط جديد ايضا
لن يتقيدوا بها وهذا ما قال اسمه تريتش
وهذا ما قالوا وهذا ما سيحدث على الارض
وهذا ما رايناه بعد سحب القرار في الامم
المتحده
في واشنطن كان منير جاوب يتحدث عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كضامن لتنفيذ
هذه ما ورد في هذا البيان من مخرجات ما
الذي يمكن ان تقدمه هو شمس على هذا الصعيد
هذا سؤال رائع اعتقد ان مصر تحاول ان تعرف
حاليا ما يمكنه ان تقوم به
منذ سنوات في الولايات المتحده الشكوى
كانت ليس هناك شريك للسلام من الجانب
الفلسطيني الان نرى بهذا التغير الجدري
الكبير من الجانب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بحيث اصبح هل لدينا شريك هناك في اسرائيل
ايضا وبالتالي ما نشهده حاليا هي ان ردود
الافعال جميع الاطراف
شديده اولا لابد ان تدخل ان رد فعل
الاسرائيليين في الشوارع هم ضد نتنياهو ما
يقوم به وبالتالي هناك الكثير من الناس في
اسرائيل
اسرائيليه يختلفون عن سياسات ولا يريدون
سياسه الحكومه الحاليه كما سمعنا مؤخرا
ارى مستقله او الامريكي
وهو وهو كان مرشح ديموقراطي ساب الرئاسه
بدا يتحدث
بصراحه بان وضع ان لابد ان الولايات
المتحده تضع شروط على اسرائيل
وبالتالي عندما اسمع
هذا الراي وهذا الاحباط الذي يتعلق بتاخير
العمل في الامم المتحده
ولابد كيف ان هناك صعوبات كثيره اعتقد ان
رؤيه واشنطن بشكل عام هي ان هذه مشكله في
غايه الصعوبه
وان السياسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اثناء هم في السلطه وهم هم عليه وان
الاسرائيليين او الناخبون قد التعامل مع
ذلك لكن اطراف الخارجيه ما يمكن نقوم به
نحن في احسن الحالات وعلى الاقل نظره
استراتيجيه واحده نحاول ان نتماسك وان
نعمل بحسن نوايا لكي نعزز ونشط السلام
انهم من الصعب جدا بالنسبه ان نقول لاي
شخص من يعيش مثل هذه الظروف ان ان نقول
لهم ما ينبغي ان يفعلوه ولكنني فعلا اعتقد
ان ثمه
الرعب في العالم كلهم يختلف انحاء العالم
ضد هذا التوجه الجديد تقوم بالحكومه
الاسرائيليه ولا تعزيزه هذا الراي
ادركنا الوقت شكرا جزيلا لك
جون نيفين غير كنت المسؤول العلامه السابق
في الحزب الديمقراطيه الامريكي
واشنطن وشكرا للدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العامل مبادره الوطنيه من رام الله
والاستاذ منير الجاوب القيادي في حركه فتح
كنت معنا ايضا من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا والى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]